bonjour nicolas vidal belle bibliothèque
bonjour merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
alors heureux de vous retrouver ce matin
dans la matinale de ft france nous
sommes à deux jours d'un nouveau samedi
de manifestations contre le pass and i
terre partout en france est ce que le
mouvement montre des signes
d'essoufflement selon vous et oui
neuvième samedi mobilisations à venir ce
11 septembre sur les boulevards et dans
les rues parisiennes vous l'avez dit à
dans le cadre d'un appel national mais
pas que vous le savez la plupart des
grandes villes de ce pays ont déjà leurs
manifs et chic des centaines et moyennes
et petites villes qui intègre vous savez
aussi le mouvement fut des semaines et
les appels sont de plus en plus nombreux
tout comme le nombre de manifestants
mais on va y revenir vous allez voir
alors ses appels il bourgeonnent sur les
réseaux sociaux dès le lundi matin sous
le déluge de hashtag de calicots
numérique qui ont évincé petit clin
d'oeil à jean michel blanquer relais
photos de chalets dit qu'on les dit tour
multicolores et les couchers de soleil
sur facebook notamment mais pour se
donner une idée de l'ampleur du
mouvement allons voir allons voir du
côté de nos voisins de la principauté de
monaco qui en lançait aussi leurs
premières manifestations contre le pass
annie terre samedi dernier avec plus
d'un millier de personnes présentes et
deux ans sont déjà prévues d'ici samedi
alors on peut pas dire entre nous que
monaco était en novembre 2018 un bastion
incandescent du gilet jaune ni un
avant-poste contestataires de la lutte
sociale et syndicale en soutien les
obligations de leurs voisins français
bien entendu alors même que vous
imaginez que ce même si le rocher
princier commencent à se teindre en
rouge version commune de paris avec un
pin's ans qui passait un brassard zone
libre ou va-t-en alors oui la france
pour ce neuvième samedi vous l'avez dit
va connaître de nouvelles manifestations
sur l'ensemble de l'hexagone est la
seule chose qui semble s'essoufler
aujourd'hui ce sont les fonctionnaires
préposé au comptage de la préfecture qui
semble ne pas tenir la cadence des
centaines de milliers de manifestants
qui passent sur leurs fenêtres
bruyamment à moins à moins qu'il ne
compte que les manifestants en tee shirt
rouge ou en t-shirt vert ou en t-shirt
bleu ou seulement ceux affublé d'un
pantalon en velours en prenant une on
compte les chiffres perd donc grosso
modo si vous êtes seul ou par groupes de
trois ou par groupes de 5 c'est foutu et
c'est comme finalement si vous étiez
resté dans le canapé à côté de votre ado
qui lui non vaccinés s'est fait évincer
du collège la semaine dernière et
forcément ça fait beaucoup moins de
monde dans les rues et pourtant le
ministère de l'intérieur d'une colère a
indiqué que samedi dernier 140 mille
manifestants ont défilé et cette
nouvelle mobilisation semble marquer une
tendance à la baisse au niveau national
à nous voilà revenus mag a lieu tout
début du mouvement des légendes à l'un
ou à longueur de journée il était bon de
temps d'assainir qu'il n'y avait presque
personne dans les rues mais seulement
rappelez-vous ultra minorité de factieux
de séditieux preto décembre et assoiffés
de chaos on entendait aussi de
mouvements de commencer à refluer dès la
mi décembre 2018 avec dugarry du recul
nous ces observations se sont révélées
un tontine approximative et surtout
active aujourd'hui le gouvernement y
leur communiquant chef recycle la même
boîte à musique avec des manifestations
contre le pass sanitaires et ali elle
est très probablement étiqueté made in
china la boîte à rythmes tourne elle
nous ressort donc les mêmes rengaines
éraillée alors on minimise on méprise on
criminalise ces centaines de milliers de
français vaccinés ou non vaccinés qui
chaque samedi protestent contre ce parce
qu'ils postent disons le d'effrayantes
questions sur nos libertés fondamentales
et plus largement sur la démocratie
sacrifier sur quoi et bien sur l'autel
de la crise sanitaire ce qui est risible
si con si un amant que les sept les
estimations du samedi à venir seront
forcément plus basse que celle du samedi
précédent le seul conseil que ce conseil
que je puisse donner au gouvernement
c'est d'éviter de donner un jour un
chiffre négatif du genre il y avait en
france ce samedi - traduit manifestants
parce que ce gouvernement la boulette du
jour et suivante plus grosse que celle
de la veille et ainsi de suite ma vie
mais nicolas pourquoi selon vous le
gouvernement minimiserait à ce point le
nombre de manifestants
c'est malheureusement assez simple à
expliquer tant ce gouvernement est
prévisible parce que faire preuve de
l'attentisme une estimation de
manifestants plus proche de la réalité
serait en réalité un aveu de faiblesse
désastre et chafiik quoi et bien l'odeur
de l'échec dans le pays se reconnaître
mathématiquement que le passé ni terre
connue une résistance importante auprès
de centaines milliers de français
vaccinons vacciner non vacciné je le
répète un qui encore l'audace ou et
l'outrecuidance d'aimer leurs libertés
fondamentales et qui le revendique
depuis mi juillet dans le calme et le
pacifisme il ne parle même pas ici de
l'efficacité du bassin ni terre il y
aurait tant à dire même le patron d'ubs
et mes lèvres milite pour sa suppression
mais les centres commerciaux et puis
emmanuel macron à cette formidable
constance depuis le début de son
quinquennat à se moquer comme d'une
guigne des manifestations populaires
quelles qu'en soient les causes alors
ils envoient quoi une armada ministériel
de pieds nickelés pour expliquer
l'inexplicable défendre l'indéfendable à
grands coups de triple salto arrière de
poirier sur une seule main la cravate à
l'envers et la mèche au vent avec un
seul mot d'ordre c'est comme ça et c'est
pas autrement alors non non les français
ne sont pas des anti vague c'est francis
ne sont pas des ignares ces français ne
sont pas des complotistes ou de
dangereux conspirationnistes il serait
bien présomptueux de donner un portrait
robot de manifestants car il n'y en a
pas tout simplement ces centaines mille
francs si de tout horizon sont
légitimement inquiet pour les libertés
publiques et individuelles qui
s'effiloche chaque jour au but dans ce
pays accélérer et ça c'est grave par la
division très dangereuse fêté par
emmanuel macron lui même entre les
vaccinés et les non vaccinés et pour
terminer alors dénigrer ces
manifestations importantes contre le
pass sanitaires à longueur de journée
pour se garder une place bien au chaud
dans le camp du bien des gens
responsables par une palanquée le
commentateur une partie de la classe
politique est reçu comme une insulte et
une humiliation à l'or finissant non pas
en chanson je suis désolé mais avec une
citation de jean gabin qui disait je
cite la capacité de parler plusieurs
langues est un atout mais celle de
savoir se taire est inestimable merci
beaucoup tout est dit merci nicolas
vidal on vous retrouve évidemment jeudi
prochain pour votre édito politique